your article that you had written a  bunch of years ago about amber amber  blackmailing johnny  and uh i remember you connected me to  him on the phone and i talked to him on  the phone did you watch any of the  trials i've watched all the traffic  so you watched the part yeah i watched  the poop we were [ __ ] dying like it  was a comedy show when we were watching  at the house when he's saying that she  tried to blame dropping a grumpy  how do you know it wasn't uh a dog feces  how do you know it was  human feces and not your dogs  they're a teacup yorkies they weigh  about four pounds each  i've picking i've picked up their fung  before yes fung a word i've never heard  oh my god it's well first of all what  you get out of it is that you know he is  an actor and he's very charming but he's  also clearly a nice guy he's a [ __ ]  one of the sweetest people i've ever met  i 100 believe that